premières lueurs du jour sur chambord le
château n'appartient pas encore aux
visiteurs à cette heure seuls les
employés ont accès au domaine depuis
plusieurs semaines en cachette ils
préparent noël
c'est barbara la maîtresse des clés qui
nous accueille
bienvenue dans le château de la démesure
426 pièce 77 et ce câblier trousseau à
la main elle ouvre une porte dit porte
c'est elle qui a la charge des
appartements du roi
j'ai l'impression de réveiller le roi de
dire c'est le levé du roi et les
courtisans sont derrière moi c'est mon
petit film du mathan quand jour chez
louis xiv
quand j'ouvre chez françois 1er c'est la
même image qui vient tout doit être
impeccable
les visiteurs vont arriver les cirrhoses
sont en action mais l'ambiance est
encore glaciale au château changement
n'est pas conçu pour être un lieu
d'habitation
donc en fait on abdou al mais tous les
cheminées qu'on veut c'est en s'éloigne
à plus d'un mètre cinquante de la
cheminée on sent pas la chaleur
sato qui est un chauffeur au rez de
chaussée il vit encore un sapin a
installé le dernier dans la salle des
chasses voix le peuple a retiré un goût
en tout 150 sapins tous offerts par des
mécènes amoureux de chambord ont été
décorés cela ne fait que cinq ans que
l'on fête noël au château la résidence
de françois 1er était délaissé en hiver
un manque à gagner important pour ce pas
les propriétés de l'état qui doit
s'autofinancer
alors on a imaginé un noël grandiose
l'été on peut avoir des journées à 9000
personnes par jour elano elle en espère
avoir 3000 et 4000 personnes par jour le
temps presse
le public arrive
le spectacle de noël va pouvoir
commencer je suis l'ordre de chambord
les courtisans accourent pour en
nouvelles au sommet
au coin du feu autre ambiance
lectures de contes et ce petit pot de
beurre on retombe un peu en enfance mais
une excellente idée
ce qu'ils font est il assez alors ses
adjoints salle hébert saleh mais soudain
la musique de lully résonne au coeur du
palais de la renaissance
on joue la belle et la bête est quasi
sûr que ça allait fonctionner donc donc
un peu de pression on est content de la
première journée soit passé et de meulan
vert pour parachever une journée royal
les petits visiteurs profitent d'une
photo avec le père noël
le stage
mais notre cadeau à nous c'est cette
dernière surprise nous vous emmenons
dans un endroit secret loin du tumulte
sous les toits de chambord là on se
retrouve dans un petit cocon où c'est
globalement silencieux bien entendu une
petite chauve-souris voilà c'est comme
ça je trouve ça assez intime où la nuit
est tombée
le calme est revenu au château chambord
et vêtus de bleu la couleur des rois